well he's
doing an incredible um energy job if you
like i mean i thought he he was filled
with energy despite everything he
certainly
looked a little bit tired that wouldn't
be surprising if he was he also sounded
tired his his voice was very gravelly uh
he's in a twilight zone because
everything's very dimly lit because
they've got a really big security issue
there i mean he's probably the most
wanted man on the russian hit list right
now so everything was very um difficult
in terms of you know we had to get in in
a secure way we're not allowed to
film anything we didn't they didn't want
us give away any positions even within
the president's office so
um they're very very
hot on that uh they didn't want to stay
in one place for very long after our
interview he was immediately whisked
away but he was angry angry and
frustrated at the rest of the world's
reactions he keeps on calling on the
rest of the world to the unite and when
i said well they are uniting aren't they
in terms of economic sanctions president
putin has seen that as a declaration of
of economic war if you like against
russia and he said he was very clear i
thought and remember this is a man who
feels his english is not that good he i
had to really press him to talk in
english and he was so determined and so
um driven to get his message across to
the english-speaking world that he he
pressed on in english and he said no
they're taking they're taking too long
we can't wait for multiple
governments to take decisions and
multiple world leaders to decide it's
the right thing he said i mentioned some
time ago to a number of world leaders
who we wouldn't name about how they
needed to cut nordstrom 2 and they
didn't until
everything started happening you
mentioned the casualties and the
civilian targets and all that and they
didn't take action so he very much
seemed to me to be saying
that
blood was on the hands of a number of
world leaders for not taking action much
much sooner and every day every hour
that goes by ukrainian
civilians and ukrainian soldiers are
being hurt and killed mario paul had
just happened as we went in to interview
him and i managed to catch him again on
the way out
to press him on what he thought should
happen to those who were targeting
hospitals and civilians particularly
this maternity hospital here's what he
had to say
all of them will be in prison that's
that's it what to see i don't want to
see how they how people cut their legs
or hands we have people we are normal
people they have to be in the prison and
stop bombing that's it what we want
him very much making clear that he wants
to see all these people particularly
president putin prosecuted for he
considers to be war crimes kay